hello everyone
just checking can
i think i can hear my voice in the
speakers can everyone here okay
cool
okay so
morning first of all thank you very much
for attending the nine o'clock slot
we were worried about how many people
would make it so yeah thanks so much for
and congratulations as well for making
it at this time
so welcome to
magic micro frontends so this is kind of
a report a story of how we've used
microfrontends within our environment so
it's a pharmaceutical regulated
environment how we've used them to help
improve some development practices and
increase agility so
i'm james and this is my colleague
nicola so we work together at sanofi
so
on the concept of sanofi to make also
our bosses happy let's give you briefly
our digital mission so what we want to
do is we want to become a leading
digital healthcare platform so how do we
want to do it we
want to change the practice of medicine
by leveraging data and digital and to
create an inspiring work environment
where we can empower people to be the
best versions of themselves
so
now that we've made them happy we're
going to continue with the presentation
cool
so first of all um maybe a quick show of
hands actually
who here works in a regulated industry
something like farmer or
a few okay cool so we just wanted to to
kind of explain some of the general
concepts make sure everyone understands
what we mean by that so
sanofi is a pharmaceutical company um
which is a really heavily regulated
industry so we're making medication
making drugs that could be injected or
ingested by a patient
so obviously the the safe
safety is critical for us so we need to
make sure that we make
the same thing every time and in our
context working as software developers
we need to make sure that any software
systems related to those manufacturing
processes quality processes
work exactly as expected and we can
prove that they have worked as specified
etc etc so some other some other
regulated industries so automotive
aerospace where clearly safety is is
really really key
and another one finance so different
context but where you need to be sure
that everything is fully auditable you
know where the money is going and
everything works as expected and is
fully traceable
so that's what we mean by regulated
environments in the pharmaceutical
industry just to give a little bit more
context we have
um this concept of gxp so we might we're
trying not to use acronyms too much but
we might accidentally refer to it during
the presentation so to explain that the
g and the p mean good practice
and the x is any kind of business domain
or business process that we might be
working with so good manufacturing
practice gmp for us that's anything
related to the manufacturing of of
medication good laboratory practice is
how we work in the labs how we're
how we're testing uh the products and so
we make software systems that interact
with
both of those processes actually so
um the the we have this concept of gxp
regulations and we refer to
those systems which must follow those
those regulations as validated
applications so
if you hear us in the presentation
actually saying validation validated gxp
that's what we're talking about
so what are some of the constraints that
we have within this industry
so
let's say nothing
on the face of it nothing special
nothing that you wouldn't expect in
normal software development processes so
say we have the standards of good
development practices solid architecture
for us the key thing and what we want to
highlight in this presentation is what
we need to prove to an auditor
so
within these regulated industries you
could be audited at any time
and that means that you may need to
present evidence of
which version is deployed in production
or which version was deployed in
production
or official test environments two weeks
ago
three weeks ago five years ago
and you need to be able to show
all of the approval chains so did your
quality assurance teams technical owners
product owners all approve the promotion
to a test environment then to another
test environment to a production
environment
you need to show
non-regression testing evidence so
things like screenshots and videos
everything is really really heavily
controlled so it's not
a crazy idea that you should do
non-regression testing or that you
should know what is deployed to
production obviously but the key thing
for us is that this can add depending on
how your systems are architected and how
your processes are designed
this can add a lot of administrative
overhead and so that's what we're here
to talk about how
by redesigning the architecture of your
systems how can you potentially reduce
some of that overhead
so
let's go back a little bit in sanofi um
to look at
how we were designing our application so
traditionally we would build monolithic
front ends
so what do we mean
um
we we have let's say some specific
business problems that we want to solve
so
might be optimization of
the release cycle for some medication so
speeding up the process for
manufacturing or releasing some
medication
this for us would be a single
application monolithic application
we might have another application so
application be
addressing a different business problem
these two are managed and built
completely separately and any change to
those applications so that let's assume
they're both regulated apps release of
medication definitely would be
any changes to those will go through a
full change control process so all of
those approvals for promotion between
environments
storing all of the testing evidence
non-regression testing for every single
component of the app every release even
if you didn't touch all of those
components
and on a bit of further analysis
what we found
as well in additional in addition to
those heavy processes
is that actually although these are
specific business problems we have a lot
of contextual data
which is interesting for users of both
applications so
represented by the different symbols
here so what what we found was that
although we had separate applications
sometimes there were components or data
which was being displayed which was
really really similar or exactly the
same thing in a slightly different
format
between applications so
some duplication of code
slightly different user experience for
looking at the same thing
between applications
and then importantly for this
presentation
more administrative overhead because
you're validating the same thing twice
or three four five times depending on
how many teams
have implemented that
so
with this in mind what is it that we
want to do and and why are we talking
about micro front ends so the mission
for us really is reduce our
administrative overheads
be more agile
so
help us to
release
release our regulated applications
faster and also
[Music]
build them faster with more
with more control
or maintaining the same level of control
i should say and also as a bonus improve
the user experience by trying to make
some of those things more consistent
between apps which are representing the
same thing
before we go into a technical demo that
that nicolo leads we'll look at a few of
the the principles a general summary of
what we mean when we talk about micro
front ends to make sure we're all on the
same page
so
the let's say the general concept for us
is applying the microservice paradigm to
the user interface so
say that concept of small services
instead of monolithic services and using
that as components within the ui
so
for us a micro front end it's an
independent section of your user
interface
and it's built really for integration
into
other applications so
what our approach generally is we'll
talk about a bit more is where we have
things which are likely to be
represented in more than one application
it's a candidate to be a micro frontend
um
and so it's it's really things which are
shared which where we're going to be
reusing them that we would try and build
as a micro front end
um it's an independent project it means
it has a separate build cycle
build process separate deployment
target and process and and that's really
important as we'll talk about for us
because remember that concept of our
really heavy
admin processes on
big builds here we're looking at how can
we make that smaller and by making the
build smaller how can we reduce some of
that administrative overhead
and theoretically you can use any ui
framework for micro front-end purists we
it's not really recommended if you have
five micro front-ends in your app that
you have five different ui frameworks
but theoretically that is possible
and and for us it's kind of a natural
progression
just the the two diagrams below that i
took from a
blog post but um
which i think is titled
uh why you probably don't need to use
micro front end but
but i like the pictures so it's all good
so we we're actually have have already
gone through the process of a very
similar process um on the back end of
carving out
sections of monolithic back ends into
reusable microservices so here we're
talking about the same concept in the
front end
with the basic goal of reducing the size
of our deployments and therefore and
therefore the scope of the deployments
and therefore the amount of
documentation that is required to go
with each deployment
that's the fundamental goal of what
we're trying to achieve
and i'm
going to give you an overview of
probably some of
what we picked as the three
kind of key concepts from
from the micro frontend world and then
nicola will do a bit of a technical demo
for each of those to explain what we
mean by them so
the first one should be
applications should be composable so
those those shared components that
contextual data which is reused in our
monolithic apps
we want to have
a catalog of micro front ends that
developers or development teams can pick
and choose from so
we need to have data xyz we'll pull the
components into our application and
multiple applications can do that
so
by doing that
you're reusing the code you're also
building a more consistent user
experience as well
next one is around loose coupling
isolated applications for us the idea is
really controlled communication between
those applications which are integrated
into a page
so
the reason that's key for us is so one
micro frontend is able to say
you can
theoretically integrate me into any
application
and that's safe to do because
i know that any data you send to me i'm
going to
filter i'm going to reject
messages which are incorrectly formatted
etc
and the other
the other concept of the loose coupling
is to avoid those applications having to
know about all of the other applications
which are integrated on the page
so it's achieving controlled
communication
but in a simple way without too much
integration between apps
and the final one which is
really really important to us is the
concept of them being independently
deployable so we need to be able to
deploy
one micro app a change to one micro app
without having to change all of the
other micro apps or without having to
change the integrating applications
which are displaying them
and with that i'll pass over to nikola
thanks james
okay so let me first
kill a bit the presentation and let's
jump a bit into our ui
so those of you who have maybe seen our
presentation in london earlier this year
we had a topic on the evolutionary
architecture i don't know why it died
okay
on the topic of evolutionary
architecture there we had a small pitch
from our millionaire boss melon task
that wanted us to fly to mars so let's
say we achieved that goal during that
presentation so we're now taking it a
step further where we want to reach
saturn at this point
so for this we've built an application
which is aeronautical by nature with
this means that parts of it should be
gxp by nature so the screen that you see
in front of yourself
is composed out of
three microfrontends
i'm going to enter more into details
about each and every of these components
a bit later and the application also has
two routes so you have the main one this
is the dashboard one and the second one
which is
astronaut running in space let's call it
a space view imagine that we have a
drone that just sees something from the
outside
so uh as i mentioned this uh this page
also has two micro front ends running
here uh and uh more on that in a second
so uh coming back to the presentation
let's talk a bit about the architecture
so
in sanofi we're
quite proud that we're sponsoring some
open source project so for this uh for
this coding demo i hope that it comes
back
for this coding demo we used vue.js
which we sponsor and we used a single
spa which is a framework how you can
build your micro front ends there are
many others on the market it's just the
one that we selected for this demo
so as i as i mentioned uh first we have
on the
dashboard i said we have three micro
front ends and on the space page we have
so the architecture of a single spy
application is quite
straightforward you have a single root
config application
that root config application is nothing
else than an entry html file which
registers your micro front end
applications
so which
i'm going to elaborate in a minute and
it uh only exists
to create the
application so you shouldn't put any
logic in it it should be like a simple
bootstrap file
so what is an application in the concept
of a single spa so it's the same as the
single page application the only
difference being is that it doesn't have
an html file i mean you can have the
template files if you're using angular
or something but still it doesn't have
any any html file that it builds
and you can have as many registered
applications in your root config as you
would like
we just selected two to make it quite
simple
and important concept of an application
since it's being registered i'm going to
show you a
code demo in a second
the application by nature is declarative
and
it should be lazily loaded so it
shouldn't be automatically loaded on the
on the bootstrap of the project it
should load on a specific activity so or
in a single spell world we call this
process mounting so it shouldn't exist
until it's being specifically called
upon
and the last concept and to be honest
our favorite is the concept of parcels
uh which you could have seen maybe on
the dashboard but more on that a bit
later
so a concept of a parcel it can be it's
similar to the application by nature the
the main difference being that parcel is
imperative by nature that means it's
called upon when you need it uh from uh
from your own ui you don't
call it upon from your root config file
and it can be as simple as a component
or it can be a full-blown application
in reality your parcels should be more
or less coming from different frameworks
an example if you use the same framework
which we do here i apologize well if you
should probably use different framework
because if you use the same one you
should probably use the exported
components function because it makes it
much more lightweight to work in this
way so
maybe to show you more in the code how
how this works
let's jump maybe just to see the
breakdown so as i mentioned we have a
root application which is this space
explorer single spot
in it as i mentioned we have a
index.html file
which provides a couple of things first
off which is important we use system.js
to load our dependencies do you see it
correctly you should okay
and
in it in the import map you will see a
couple of things
initially you will see that we import
our applications
we also import our parcels
and we import some shared dependencies
now we preload some of this data again
this is quite bootstrapped and at the
end we come to the more important part
and this is the basic purpose of a root
application
which
loads and registers a single spa
application so for an application to be
registered you need to call it based on
the you need to give it a name you need
to call based on its import which we
defined earlier and you need to provide
an activity function so
meaning where this single page
application will be shown so this one
will be shown on every route while the
space application will be shown only on
the space route so that means it won't
use anything in your browser until it
reaches that point
so
coming maybe to the next concept that we
mentioned which was an application in
this case we have two of them one is the
space explorer and the other one is
space
so in the space explorer
i'm going to show you the configuration
is the same for the for the other one
you need to provide a couple of things
that application can be recognized and
that it can properly work so you need to
we have also some utility files that
single spa provides that can help you
bootstrap these things quickly but you
need to provide the following functions
in all cases application needs to have a
bootstrap function it needs to have a
mount function and a noun mount function
there is also an unload which is an
optional one we didn't use it in this
case we didn't find it quite useful to
show you anything with it
what is important about these function
is they all need to be asynchronous
meaning they should always return a
promise that your
single spawn knows how to properly
handle them
so the last concept that we mentioned
is the concept of uh parcels
so as i mentioned parcel can be as big
as an application or as small as a
component in our case let's let's take
the saturn one this one is uh
as the size of the application so
by its nature the way you declare uh
parcel it's the same as you would
declare an application you again need to
provide a couple of uh life cycle
functions
you have a bootstrap you have mount and
you have unmount these look a bit more
complex they're just adding logs that i
will use later to
elaborate a bit how how the application
works
so
again the it should always return a
promise and unlike
how we called
how we declare the application in the
root config
we
specifically mount this one
on demand so you can see in example here
we first need to how how do you mount a
parcel you need to define a slot where
you want to have it and you need to call
now we're in the space explorer
application just if i skip the step
sorry
so in here we want to call on the mount
during the mount process we want to
mount the component for it we need to
get that dom element
and we need to provide to the mount
parcel function
which parcel we would like to load and
in which area of
the code we would like to show it
and with this
i will hand over to james
to
maybe continue
talking about
the communication
cool
so yeah let's
just
just go through a quick reminder of some
of the
thank you cool
of those of those main concepts and what
what's important for us so there are
obviously other benefits but what's
really important for us so
first one we're going to look at is
loose coupling
the application being isolated and
controlling communications between micro
applications
so the general concepts
yes we should have things as isolated as
possible but we also want to have good
user experience so there has to be some
sharing of contextual data in in the ui
so
each micro app knows
for example which filters are applied or
if a button has been clicked etc
so we're looking at how we can how we
can control that
so single spa
has a few
recommendations of how you could
approach this
first one
is to export some functions from your
micro app or micro front end i should
say
for us we we've avoided this approach um
the reason is because we feel it kind of
exposes some of the internals of your
micro front end that we really want to
avoid doing
um
and you could potentially have some
issues in your application some run
runtime errors in your app
if the signature of your exported
function changes so if you change the
name of it or change some of the
parameters that you expect it could
cause issues in the application which is
integrating
your micro app micro front end
second possibility second recommendation
from single spa is to use cross micro
front end imports so let's say a similar
concept to the first one but in this
case it's kind of a shared library so
for all of your different micro apps you
have a shared library
exporting some utility functions to to
let you do things like
manage authentication between
applications
um and again for us at least in this
this fundamental thing we're trying to
achieve of just sharing some ui
state or some simple actions
it's it's a bit too complex and results
in
some coupling that we want to avoid so
in addition to the fact that you could
have some issues if your signatures
change if function signatures change
if you make a change to a micro app
which impacts
one of the signatures you have to
republish the micro app like front end
sorry
the shared library and then anything
using that shared library so you're kind
of increasing the complexity
of having
you're moving away from that concept of
independent deployments which is so
important to us
so
the one that we chose and what we'll
focus on and nicola will show in detail
is to use event emitters so essentially
kind of a pub sub model
to emit some events which application
micro front-ends can choose
to listen to they can listen to them
they can ignore them
they can reject them potentially
so for
for us it's really the preferred
approach
and what we are using for sharing simple
ui states
it avoids
some runtime errors that could occur if
you're like we talked about with
function signatures changing
and it has to be done in a controlled
way but for us your worst case is that
if something changes in your application
is not listening to the correct event
you might be looking at potentially the
wrong the wrong view or the wrong filter
within the application so you have to do
this
really with care so you know that you're
not going to accidentally show some
completely incorrect data to for
something critical that users need to
see but for us it's kind of a safe way
to keep it simple
and avoid those runtime errors but still
keeping some control
and
that's you
thank you
so for the coding demo let's maybe first
take a look how this is implemented in
the ui so what we're going to show you
now is
the space view i'm just waiting for this
to blink a bit so as i mentioned earlier
this is um
composed out of two micro frontends you
can also see it here on the right side
you have two applications that are
currently in the mounted state one being
the space application the one that you
see as a content
and the space explorer one
so
space explorer is consisted out of this
navbar that you see at the top and this
button deploy astronaut in the bottom
well for me left corner
so
what we did is
we're going to emit an event from the
space explorer component and if i clear
this a bit you will see how it goes so
from the
application space explorer we're
deploying an astronaut and the
components already another application
space is at this at this moment
handling this event and you could have
seen that we triggered a ui
change where the astronaut just moved
and yeah came closer to you guys
so
how is this implemented
let's maybe quickly see it in the
component here
so in the application space explorer the
the main one where the button is located
like i said there is nothing special
here you just have one button which has
uh on click event uh it makes and click
event deploy astronaut
which basically is a new custom event we
can use the regular events we just use
this one because we want to provide some
contextual data to the to the other
component
and the one thing that you can notice
here is that we're providing two things
in this case we're providing the name
and surname so we of of an astronaut
while in the console log we just caught
the name
meaning that the contract isn't actually
respected and it's it's more of a
problem that also james will will jump
into a bit later
and i can show you a bit how it uh works
on the space component
where
in its application
basically there is nothing
happening except when the component is
mounted it adds an event listener it
listens for the same event and from the
detail which we emitted there is just
passing in the name which we're just
logging and we just set the state that
okay at this moment the astronaut is
deployed and you cannot deploy it
anymore
so maybe to back to james to
talk a bit more on the next steps for
communication
cool thanks
so yeah as we we mentioned we've used
event emitters as a lightweight and for
and it's a scalable solution as well so
we're using browser events
so
any application which is integrated can
listen for those browser events or not
depending on how the app is designed
and for us it's really the best way to
avoid coupling between front ends
that's kind of opinionated so obviously
there are other ways in
in the single spa documentation there
are other ways that you could imagine
but for us it's one that works
the drawback
um for our current implementation of
this is that there's no built-in
contracts of what events you should be
sending
and no real built-in validation
so that you obviously saw a very naive
naive version of it where this poor
astronaut is just deployed when someone
randomly clicks a button
um without any kind of safety checking
um
and yeah this this for us is kind of a
drawback so as some next steps that
we're looking at
first one is looking at how we can
export a types library so we know
um so we can essentially define a
contract for the messages that the
specific application expect to receive
so as a
i'll say parent app but an application
which is integrating several micro front
ends
could have a documented recorded way of
knowing that they're sending the
expected messages or broadcasting the
expected messages
the second one
as i said it was a naive
implementation of it but what we want to
do is have a really robust way
of validating that the incoming messages
are are valid and this is this is
actually the more important side of it
is
inside the micro front end
validating really strictly that the
message i've received is a valid one uh
it's
i don't know the parameters are as
expected the data structure is expected
or the values which are given
are within the range that i expect
within the application so this is
probably this is the key area that we're
focusing on now
um
and the final one that we we didn't
mention but it's a little bit of a
change from what we've been saying is
so far
we're talking only about event emitters
um but what we're looking at is how we
can use url parameters for filtering
because
the url parameters are accessible to all
micro apps
and it's probably a better pattern for
us to use but we're not using it yet so
something that we are exploring
so next concept uh we already looked at
composability
so
how do i
sorry you have a question
go ahead um
not without validation and the contract
in place it won't avoid it completely
so and it avoids it in a sense if your
parent application starts emitting some
event and you don't subscribe to it you
won't have any runtime issues
but if you subscribe to the same event
and you expect something that you don't
get or you get something completely
different you're going to have it so
this is what james
explains so for the next steps we need
to have some contracts in place between
the micro front ends that are going to
be shared among the teams so as an
interface of communication between them
and how they're going to integrate one
with another
how do you create a
shared developers
between the between every micro
front-end
component if you have different premium
or
we're going to talk more about the team
topologies a bit later in the
presentation if this is uh
your question about team structure or
about the technical implementation
of the browser event
from a package
and another mdm package has been
listening to it how
so this is where the root application
comes into place everything is coupled
together and there so everything is
bundled so when you emit an event it's a
it's a native browser implementation so
at this moment you admit events to the
whole everybody who listens to it
doesn't matter in which application is
it is it a react or is it view is it
angular if it subscribes to a specific
global event listener so the one that
you have at the window
you're going to catch the the event so
you can have multiple subscribers in
this case even
my next question
because i was concerned about the
concurrent
two
regards
because of the triggering of the event
and it's the broadhouse issue
yes
no worries
cool good questions
thank you
um so yeah composability so this is the
concept of being able to
assemble
small micro front ends into a larger
application um and i don't have very
much to say on it because it's all in
the demo
yep
okay so uh
the next thing that we're going to take
a look into is the
parcels so the thing that you could have
seen earlier is when we mount this you
can see that the
application once this this page is
loaded as i said this has three micro
front ends running well at this moment
only two
uh one being the space explorer and you
can see also maybe
looking back that the space is not
mounted here that means that it's not
accessible at this
route
and uh here where the crew manifest is
not mounted we are imperatively going to
call it now so we want to call upon the
crew manifest to to yeah appear and you
can see that the event was not event
well the mount function was called from
the space explorer micro front end and
the parcel crew manifest caught it and
finished the the mounting
so
with this let me show you maybe how the
code looks like for the
for the mounting of the
sorry second it's in the space explorer
one here we have on the
oh sorry wrong component
here we have a button like i said that
has a button pressed
it follows the same logic basically on
on button pressed we're going to either
depending if if the component is mounted
and we're going to mount it to unmounted
mount it's the same as i described
earlier for the one in the
in parcel saturn so you can see that
we we need to provide the dom element
where it's going to render we provide a
function that
imports it and we yeah send the dom
element and we update the
through manifest state at this moment
for the unmount uh you will notice that
during the mount we store this in a in a
local variable uh and if you want to
unmount it you can call upon it just
provide sorry you can just call upon the
function on mount which again it should
be a promise it returns uh
it it returns just yeah uh true or false
the component is then unmounted that
life cycle is updated and we update the
crew manifest state
the implementation you saw earlier again
it's it's the same one is in the as in
the parcel saturn we have just a
bootstrap function mount and unmount so
nothing spectacular is happening on the
parcel that you haven't seen so far
so coming back to the
presentation
is
why are parcels important to us
okay
so parcels uh as you could have seen we
composed a ui which which was a
dashboard
okay
and uh
it was composed out of various elements
in our case we used view for
all all examples in reality you
shouldn't do that you should have one
maybe if it comes from react the other
one from angular
maybe turn one from you but as james
said probably shouldn't mix and match so
many things
but as you can imagine at sanofi it's a
corporation quite large in its size with
multiple uh
development departments and we have a
diverse portfolio of applications where
each web application can use a different
framework and as you can imagine we're
present on the market for quite some
time so we had a couple of evolutionary
steps which we need to integrate
together we need to refactor some things
in
our department primarily we work mostly
with react and view but i can't swear
that we don't have anything else in in
our portfolio
and as you could have seen earlier when
james was showing we have a
functionality overlap between the
applications where different business
cases have been resolved multiple times
by different teams and basically
creating a variation in the user
experience for the same subset of data
or same subset of services so the teams
unintentionally created
functionality duplication and in some
cases even even code duplication
so
as we had some experience with working
in microservices and uh creating some
let's call it business data set so we we
already separated our data we separated
our backend services we
we restructured the way we work but the
only thing that remained was these
monolithic front ends so
in order you cannot just say let's use
parcels and everything is going to be
magical we had to restructure our teams
a bit so we created something like a
pod-like structure
where we had enabling teams working
mostly on these
i apologize transversal applications
like micro apps like we saw here like
this
saturn or a crew manifest which you can
import in multiple applications that
would use it b to gxp or non-gxp alike
and we had the product teams mostly
focused on the business value so
delivering uh delivering business
products to our
customers and they were responsible for
integration and domain specific
functionality
so the two teams just had to interact
with each other so for this we just
composed some interfaces where one is
providing to another okay this is what
i'm going this is what we delivered this
is how you can integrate it and as as
james said we're now exploring the ways
how we can document this more in a
better way so far we're mostly um on uh
i don't want to say paper based but
confluence based documentation in this
case
and
maybe jumping to the next step which is
being independently deployable and i
think this is the the part which is
mostly interesting to everybody working
in a validated environment
so
what does this mean
micro frontends by default benefit from
being independently deployable you can
easily migrate you can easily experiment
with it
and we're going to talk in this section
a bit more about how we can
independently deploy components and how
we can share dependencies between the
components
so
let me show you a quick demo
on how this works
let's jump briefly into our browser
and uh let's let's take a look back into
the space explorer page where as you
could have seen in the
extension that i use we have two micro
front ends space and space explorer at
this moment they are both mounted and in
our root configuration we just declare
them so the application running on port
3000 is our root app so you will see
that nothing changes here the time is
still the same
but let me just quickly deploy an
updated version
of
space updated which is running on a
different port let me quickly copy it
okay
and
we can
in a development environment quickly
override the space and if i'm not
mistaken it's js app.js so here we have
a red rocket and now we want to just
apply override and
without even changing the root
application
you just independently deployed the a
new space application something changed
below it
so at this point you can imagine that
the space application was gxp it went
through its all its quality processes
you have every following documentation
but the ux for the users changed without
any deploy being
changed on the on the root config or on
the space explorer application
so maybe this was a an ugly demo so let
me show you in a bit different way let's
clean this up and return it to the
initial state
and let's just jump back into the
terminal and quickly kill this one
and i'm going to kill the main space
application and i'm just going to
readjust the port so that you see
of of a space updated so you're going to
see that nothing changes except the port
where it listens
and i'm going to redeploy
just this one should run on port 8083
now yes i hope it's visible
and
if we take a look here it should
refresh
if you take a look here now we have
again completely independently deployed
so you have the same url nothing changed
but a completely different application
running under the hood
and this is actually the main benefit
that we want to present to you and this
is how we solve this
let's call it a big issue of how to
accelerate our delivery in the sense of
regulated environment
so
next topic here that
i mentioned briefly was shared
dependencies
so if if you remember when i talked
about the
root configuration
in the index.html we had a couple of
things which we shared and we we
imported with system.js we called upon a
single spa view and view router and we
provide them to the to all applications
so to configure it you just import it
and in
applications where you want to use it
you just need to configure your
webpack that uses which are view and
view router so to be honest
you can and you don't have to use shared
dependencies we find it uh quite useful
that we use it especially since we
reduce the the overhead of loading same
things multiple times over time this way
we increase the performance
and
yeah
i don't know
if i have no yeah that's that's on the
shared dependencies again if you have
different frameworks maybe you want to
add also react but
as a good rule of thumb i would say you
should try to just load large
dependencies and share them while the
smaller ones you can probably load at
the level of the application
so
why do we find independent deploys so so
good to us well they're easy
they're quick to set up they work by
default they allow us to share the
dependencies between the application and
one thing that we haven't touched so far
and it's quite important from the
quality perspective and that's testing
so with this we
keep the testing capabilities of each
micro app to the team or micro front-end
application to each team that develops
this one so at this moment you only unit
test
test integration you test the end-to-end
at the level of the application that
you're
developing
and at the moment when you integrate it
you only test the integration between
those two applications you don't have to
retest the behavior of the application
below it the one that's that's
integrated in it
and i'm going to hand over to james
thank you
so yeah a quick wrap-up of
looking at what we've seen and some
additional problems and challenges that
we we've had so maybe to to summarize
um
it is a really nice approach in our in
our context it's working and it has
helped us to improve some processes but
it's definitely not without its
challenges
so
a few a few of those so things we didn't
already talk about
first one
i think is the learning curve so for
developers so
first of all understanding
the concepts of single spa or general
generally micro front ends the the
overall overarching principles
it took a little bit longer than we
expected for everyone to ourselves
included
and we're still learning but for
everyone to understand those general
principles before getting to the point
of being able to
actually go ahead with the technical
implementation
um
and then when you get to the technical
implementation
it's a little bit more tricky to get
started than we had anticipated so
if you're going to go with this approach
make sure that people are in an
environment where they have time to
learn those things where they don't have
the pressure to deliver something really
critical in this manner
it's really important
and probably choose something
with a really small scope that's
lightweight and non-critical to try with
this approach first so that leads us on
to the next point about restructuring
existing projects so
it's taken us some time even though we
defined the approach
the theory is really nice everyone
agrees with it it takes some time to
make your make sure the micro front ends
are actually integrated and replacing
that functionality that we're trying to
replace
so yeah again do this progressively try
and choose something simple first so
you can really prove the value and
demonstrate the concept to to everybody
um
and and prove that it's worth doing
the next point so nicola touched on this
is something where we haven't i'd say we
haven't got to where we want to be yet
so it's a work in progress but is around
restructuring teams to fit this model so
we had obviously come from that model
where we had
what we refer to as pods the teams
working on big monolithic
front ends
accidentally duplicating pieces of code
between them
[Music]
and that requires some some carve out so
into what nicola i think referred to as
enabler teams and product teams so where
the enabler team is working on the the
smaller components that could be shared
and the product team is more of a an
integration team and then working on
some of the business or domain specific
code um
this
yeah as with any team restructure takes
time needs to be thought out um and and
it's one of the challenges and something
that's ongoing for us
and then the final one which is probably
the the biggest challenge for us and one
where you need to throughout this whole
journey
keep your qa team or whoever the people
are who are helping you with those
documentation processes the
administrative processes
they need to understand what it is that
you're doing so
make sure that you've shared the concept
with them make sure you take the time to
explain fully what it is that you're
trying to achieve
how it's going to streamline the process
and fundamentally make sure that
once you've implemented the micro front
end
that you're also removing some
administration and documentation from
other parts of the process so you're not
just adding a new technology you have to
remove some of the overhead at the same
time and so that's really working so
closely with the qa team
that that's yeah it's a fundamental
thing
a quick reminder um
just to finish of some of the guiding
principles that we touched on
so
remember the mission so the mission for
us was to reduce the administrative
overhead
um increase agility for regulated app
development and deployment
so help us to move faster
[Music]
so some of those principles so the micro
front end is an independent application
and it has to be treated in that way
in terms of your technical processes but
more importantly for us in terms of your
administrative processes so
smaller releases
with a smaller scope
and documentation covering that scope
not the scope of an entire monolithic
application
communication
so this is referring back to the loose
coupling communication between apps so
event communication works really well
for us
but you must have strict validation
which we
are like we said are not where we want
to be yet and
most importantly keep it simple so
try not to have
or let's say avoid tight integration
between each part of the app
because it will just become overly
complex you'll introduce tight coupling
and in many cases it's probably not
necessary
dependency sharing
is really nice
nice feature to reduce the size of your
download but
make sure that you have a clear testing
strategy so that you can prove to an
auditor or justify to your qa team that
we can have these shared dependencies
because we know
thanks to our automated testing strategy
that we're not going to break anything
and
final points
as the previous slide is about the team
so
really follow that
microservice principle actually of
having a team for your microservice have
a team for your micro front end app
um
don't try to have
at least this didn't work for us don't
try to have bigger product teams
working on the product and then also
working on
some independent micro front ends really
try and carve out those for us it's
these two concepts
probably will be organization dependent
but
think through the team take the time to
think about how you want to change
things and also you can experiment over
time you probably won't get that
structure right the first time
and
with that just a couple of links to
share so
first one is the github repo that for
the code nikola shed and the second one
is a link to the single spar website
and
thank you very much
and we have some time for questions if
you have any
go ahead
i was wondering if you have some of this
component that you know that you know
the second component you have a way for
those two components to
interact so you talk about this
component instead of another it sort of
have an implication on
on the first component or do you keep
the concerns completely separate
we try to keep the concerns as separate
as possible because this this way if you
just tie the communication across so one
component triggers another triggers
another you could easily create a logic
that you don't want to have at this
moment so
you you would tightly couple things you
would expose the knowledge of a root
application to the subset of
applications that compose it so we find
it as an anti-pattern in this sense if i
understood the correct question
i badly correctly my work in the very
mess with the whole dark right
on my page so if you actually avoid the
need to regress and test the product
when you release a microwave
it seems like from the
regulated environment there's still the
risk that you could blow up the entire
product when one micro and then when you
want an immune system
you
assume that you're
you know the icd and the practice to
prevent that and then it still allows
you hit the nail on the head with the
cicd processes so yeah the critical
thing is making sure that you do have
some
say
i don't know integration or end-to-end
tests which are in place which allow you
to to make sure you're not gonna
release something which is
gonna crash everything
um
but the the point is that
those are executed automatically but
they're not considered as a change to
the the parent or that integrating app
so it's more in releasing my micro app i
will trigger i'll automatically trigger
this test suite
but i'm not going to have to go through
all of the administrative overhead of
doing two separate releases or two
separate test suite executions
yeah
is that
major updates of the shared dependencies
and let's say that one micro front end
is used in several applications and now
one is application
you mean like like like view you okay
so for this we have we have a pattern
that we use so in majority of cases we
have a standardized things so we have a
certain version of view that we use for
us
but in reality how it works the majority
majority of your applications at least
for us are running on the same version
so we keep this one as a shared
dependency and of course it's possible
that one of your products is going to
evolve in example this this whole repo
is written with vu2 maybe somebody wants
to use the composition api and switch to
v3
you can do that you just don't configure
your webpack to to take the shared
dependency it rather uses the view from
from below it can even use react so like
i said in this example we just stick
with view but you can have as many
dependencies they can be shared or they
they don't have to be we just
follow the practice that we share the
dependency that's used by majority of
the applications that we have so if at
one point view 3 becomes the dominant
one only then we would update the root
configuration that we share the
dependency of u3 until this happens we
share the view too
well with with a specific micro front
end yes yes
unfortunately it's unavoidable but the
same can be said that you load also
react and view and angular at some point
so
it's it's simply unavoidable and this is
exactly why we we want to use this
one shared dependency is
automatically understood by the single
spa
so in the root config you need to import
the ones that you want to use so this is
the one that's going to declare for
every every micro front end or every
parcel that you want to use there you
you need to define it
but on the level of the application you
need to configure or each micro front
and you need to configure a webpack do
you want to use this shared dependency
or if you want to use the the one that
you have
well in reality one once you start
building microfrontence you need to have
root config per each uh project so you
need to have for each of these
applications if you want to
independently deploy it you need to have
a root config that's going to deploy it
so everybody's responsible for the one
that that their application uses so
maybe you're going to have multiple
applications and you will you will be
responsible for that one so the the
integrating app is the one that's going
to manage the root config and that will
say okay i need to import micro front
end x y and z and that they will manage
that root config exactly
go ahead
we talked about learning curve and
things but for us it's
the problem we're trying to focus on and
highlight in this presentation for us is
how do we streamline the process
and it's
making sure that people really
understand the concepts
and accept that if we implement this
the deal is that you help us to
streamline the process behind it and so
that's always you know within sanofi
people we have really very good
relationships between dev and qa teams
but it always takes time for people to
understand the concept and figure out
okay that means we can
take this approach in the documentation
or this approach in the release
so that's the that for me is probably
the biggest challenge of getting that
message through and getting it
widespread and understood and accepted
enough to be to be taken on board
maybe to rephrase this it's always
easier to explain this concept to
technical personnel working on
implementing this rather than quality
personnel that doesn't have a technical
background in this sense so this was
this was the most difficult part to
change the processes within and
make it uh widespread so we're running
also some internal presentations trying
to educate people on how this how this
can help us accelerate our development
processes
let's save the money
be the leader
we missed that one and we're going in
the next
um i think we've run out of time i want
to say thank you so much to everyone for
for coming um we hope you took something
from the presentation so thanks a lot
guys thank you everybody
you